Let's talk about Elizabeth Warren.
Uh, 2020 Democratic candidate Elizabeth Warren
has refused an invitation to do a town hall
on Fox News.
And there's a lot to discuss here.
And, and I'm very interested in many of the
elements that are going on here.
So you might remember that not long ago weeks
was it a couple months times flying, uh, 2020
Democratic candidate Bernie Sanders did a
Fox News town hall and he absolutely crushed
it.
He had the entire room clapping for Medicare
for all.
He schooled the moderators, Martha Maccallum
and Bret Baier on everything from healthcare
to taxes to economics.
I mean, really just everything.
It went really, really well for Bernie Sanders
and it went really poorly for Fox News.
Elizabeth Warren has been invited to do her
own town hall on Fox News and she's taking
a different approach.
She is turned it down and she says, Fox News
is a hate for profit racket that gives a megaphone
to racists and conspiracists, which of course
is completely true, but there's still a question
of whether Elizabeth Warren might benefit
in the net by appearing on Fox News and talking
about what are mostly very good ideas that
she has as compared to ignoring Fox News all
together.
Now, this is so funny.
There are people attacking me on Twitter already.
Like I haven't even commented on the Elizabeth
Warren Fox News town hall thing.
I'm, I'm commenting on it now and people are
tweeting me saying, David, you are going to
be a hypocrite because you praised Bernie
Sanders for doing the town hall, and you're
going to praise Elizabeth Warren for not doing
the town hall.
But remember what I said when Bernie did the
town hall is I think that there are two legitimate
perspectives here.
Do the town hall knowing that Fox News is
the propaganda arm of the Trump administration
because you're making the calculation that
you'd rather reach some portion of their audience
that is convincible.
Even though it's a total hate for profit racket,
as Elizabeth Warren points out, that's a legitimate
idea, legitimate point of view.
It's also legitimate to say, I'm not going
to implicitly or explicitly give attention
to this propaganda network, nor allow them
to use me, uh, to continue their hate for
profit racket.
Both are legitimate, but you don't have to
take my word for it.
Let's actually look at what I said the day
I covered the Bernie Sanders town hall.
But there were sort of two main arguments
leading up to this about whether Bernie Sanders
should or shouldn't appear.
The argument against Bernie appearing is a
very simple one, which is Fox News is the
propaganda arm of the Trump administration.
It is not going to be, uh, a town hall that
is a sort of fairly set up.
It is going to be an audience that is going
to have a hand pick people from political
groups including turning point USA, which
happened.
It's going to be one that most likely will
turn into a two on one sort of argument between
two Fox News moderators and Bernie Sanders,
which it did.
And uh, it's a net loss.
Don't give them the ratings by appearing.
That was the argument against Bernie appearing
on the other side.
The argument for Bernie appearing, uh, is
listen, these are people who otherwise may
never even get a real understanding from Bernie
himself about what his policies are.
Most people, not in the physical audience,
but in the Fox News television audience probably
are not going to be voting for the Democrat
in November of 2020.
But if Bernie can convince just one or 2%
of the people in the audience, it's worthwhile
and he could reach people that otherwise we'll
never have anything break their echo chamber,
pierce their propaganda, uh, and therefore
it's worth Bernie appearing both of respectable
and defensible points of view.
So again, both are legitimate strategies.
Each candidate should handle it, how they
see fit.
They don't, oh, Fox News, anything.
Their calculation should be, what do they
want to do?
How do they want to use Fox News if at all,
to push their agenda and to push their platform.
Uh, and if they don't want to do it, that's
perfectly reasonable.
Now there will be all of the normal responses
to Elizabeth Warren's decision that we can
imagine.
And we would expect Elizabeth Warren is scared
or she's avoiding debates and town halls.
Well, Elizabeth Warren has done endless town
halls and she's faced countless questions.
She recently took questions completely unprepared
when her plane from, I believe it was a DC
or LaGuardia to Charleston, I believe it was,
got very, very delayed.
She held an impromptu town hall.
She's faced questions from adversarial people.
And people on her side saying that in particular
she believes Fox News is a bad faith actor,
is very different than saying she's afraid
of or won't participate in town halls or adversarial
interviews.
You also have to consider, and this is something
that I've not seen, uh, talked about since
the story broke, given how poorly the Bernie
Sanders town hall went for Fox News.
I mean a room full of people clapping for
Medicare for all a and clapping for Bernie
Sanders on Fox News.
That's not great for Fox News.
I would be shocked.
A Fox allowed an Elizabeth Warren town hall
to go the same way that the Bernie Sanders
town hall went.
My guess is that they would be much more prepared
to really make her look bad in a way that
they were unable to make Bernie Sanders look
bad.
Now, Elizabeth Warren is smart and quick enough
that she still would probably do okay.
But I think that that's also probably a consideration
in the last seven days as you may have noticed,
I have been pushed more and more in the direction
of Elizabeth Warren.
Um, I still find her quite uncharismatic on
a personality level.
I don't see her really connecting with large
swaths of voters particularly well, but as
I told you yesterday, her policy proposals
or detailed most of them I agree with, although
I have some questions, uh, about some of them.
And since the fiasco that was the handling
of her DNA test, she has been making many
of the right decisions and I would be glad
to vote for her against Donald Trump and I
would be glad to vote for Bernie Sanders against
Donald Trump as well.
Uh, many similarities between the two important
differences, which we've discussed, but there
are some significantly a good candidates that
are running right now on, on the democratic
side and good for Elizabeth Warren and this
entire book, by the way, this may have inadvertently
had the very successful popularizing of the
term hate for profit racket about Fox News,
which has sort of instantly been mainstreamed,
um, and has appeared in all sorts of articles
and commentaries.
So good for Elizabeth Warren.
Good for Bernie Sanders.
I respect both of their decisions, but I would
like to hear from you.
Do you think Elizabeth Warren is making the
correct decision given all of the circumstances
or would you rather see her?
Do you think it would be the right decision
for her to do the Fox News?
Yeah,
town hall.
Let me know on Twitter at D Pacman, make sure
you're following me and follow the show as
well.
At
David Pakman show, we'll take a quick break
and be back after this